what's up it's us again it's Tuesday
just put up the show about Samuel little
earlier usually you guys are enjoying
that the weird thing is that I got a
message like not too long after we put
it up and said holy crap like what
fortuitous timing this was because
apparently the oxygen network is either
just released or is going to be
releasing this week like a documentary
about him and I'm like holy crap I
didn't even know that it's like we
always like stumble into this kind of
[ __ ] cuz remember like when when we did
the show about Steven Seagal and
somebody messaged me and said oh it's
like really interesting you're doing
that is because it's like his birthday
this week or something like that like I
didn't totally even know that I just
like accidentally way cuz I was
switching [ __ ] around on the schedule
I'm like yeah let's do that this week
why not that's because I'm involved in
it because you got like say god damn
quantum computation put my face in the
damn microphone I got that quantum
computation going on that supercomputer
well no you [ __ ] it is just the force
it's no it's must be me that has it
because I'm the one that I'm the one
that decides like what topics we do what
week I have like the whole year like but
I brought I said it though and that was
in the randomizer and it came because I
even was able to compute the random
events on a quantum level that's
something that happens tuned into like -
did he get the castle sphere the crustle
verse the writer
yeah the larger Gestalt of the whole
here the door damn door vibrating yeah
every time like yeah it always does that
okay there's all kind of [ __ ] going on
okay yeah so what are we gonna talk
about today okay like last night on
Netflix you guys probably know this by
now cuz we talked so much about [ __ ]
Tiger King and everybody is like talking
about Tiger king yeah so they put up the
new APIs is not really a new episode but
same another day like it update about it
they had like Joel McHale who used to be
and I think he's going on talk soup or
something like that and he's like from
his apartment obviously because
everyone's on lockdown still and he
interviewed like a bunch of the people
that had been on the show like kind of
asking them what the update was like
since the show had when
like how they were dealing with everyone
being like recognizing them everywhere
and [ __ ] like that
it was pretty entertaining it's funny
because he asked pretty much every
single one do you think that Joe should
be in jail and all of them were like oh
yeah absolutely yeah
well justjust just a guy who lost his
arm or the girl who lost his arm you
know she said she doesn't care what we
yeah he's transgender but because they
asked they're like well they kept
referring to you as a girl and you show
even though you identify as a manager
it's like wow just like it didn't really
bother me that much she said that she
thought justice was served the way I
interpret you seem like he seemed like
he was trying to be very diplomatic
about it because he seemed to he seemed
to like like Joe okay but he's like you
know my loyalty is always to the Tigers
yeah I mean he gave me get upset that
the [ __ ] tiger bit his arm off yeah
well here's the thing here's the thing
that about that show that's stuck with
me having worked with the animals myself
you know in the horse business when at
the guy who when the guy who actually
produced the damn documentary Seth said
that Joe was terrified of those Tigers I
started to make a lot yeah that was an
interesting revelation wasn't it he's
having other people do all that [ __ ] he
was terrified of them [ __ ] things and
I was going like ah yeah cuz I'm looking
back on it he did act kind of [ __ ]
terrified around
Betsy when that one grabbed his [ __ ]
foot yeah that was crazy he overreacted
a little bit I think although [ __ ] what
did he do well yeah well I would have
kicked it in the [ __ ] face but what
would hot would that Tiger reacted by
strike him back probably yeah so maybe
she you tiny little and then when a gay
Nick came out that he had [ __ ]
executed was it five or six totally
healthy Tigers but just because he
needed cage space I started to [ __ ]
click yeah and a couple of them said
this like yeah yeah there was weird [ __ ]
that went down like that in the in the
horse business a mention no names but
just sometimes horses were put down
because of financial problems you know I
mean
it's very hard to give away a horse
especially during the time all that
stuff was going on the only people that
can take it or people who are equipped
to take care of ORS and they were
[ __ ] filled up this is during the
collapse of the horse industry yeah a
lot of horses just the they no longer
had owners and the barns can't keep them
yet I mean they're not gonna feed him
you can't give them away yeah and you
can't give them to a random person
living in an apartment what are they
gonna do with them then hey money can't
fit a horse in an apartment pretty dip
so they were yeah horses were put down
but it was kind of understandable and
they're not endangered that's yeah
that's a that's a little bit different I
brought you know not think that's good
either and that makes me sad too but
it's like horses aren't an endangered
species that you just can't give horses
away yeah that's something that's a big
problem because people have tried that
you give a horse to somebody the next
thing you know you go back three months
later to check on that horse and that
horse is just skin and bones starving to
death because the person can't feed the
[ __ ] horse yeah it's expensive they
ate a lot so no big yeah so
unfortunately that [ __ ] goes down but to
have that go down in the tiger industry
that's a [ __ ] me I'm just not cool
with that at all well it's just
unforgivable there's only so few tigers
left in the wild and there's no wild for
them to really go back to I can that but
a cat is very different a big cat is
very different from a horse just in
intellect and and and you know actually
a horse might be as intelligent I don't
think cats are too you know they don't
really figure things out but I do
believe that big cats kind of have a
feeling of consciousness more than a
horse you know I'm talking about yeah a
cat's intelligent is a little more
people bit more person like compared to
a horse a horse is a herd animal that
horses are creatures you know I mean you
never want to any creature to suffer
needlessly you know and very rarely does
is that ever it's doesn't that'll need
to suffer but what I was just saying was
is like cats I think have a more of a
presence to them than horse
a lot of times well like you said it
might be the difference between the
horses being herd animals if that's
being generally kind of a [ __ ]
independent independent hunters and
although they do live in social groups
but yeah but then they ended up being a
little more doglike like lions are kind
of dog like cats or kana or Tigers seem
to be less doglike a more man-like in a
way you know I mean they're yeah I feel
like you're dealing with an individual
well inside a scale yeah like when they
talked to you know to a lot of Joe's
former employees like on this particular
special where he was interviewing them
you know a lot of them said that that
all of the Tigers just like house cats
they have their own personalities and
you know they have their own way of
doing things
so and you can have they can have a
relationship with you
yeah and it really came across because
obviously they're not gonna interview I
think everybody they interviewed for
this follow up was like you know the
more likeable people like the normal
people on the [ __ ] show other than
Jeff Lowe like but he was the less weird
of the weirdos I mean yes he has a wife
and a bunch of other girlfriends and
what I don't know there's no yeah that's
their thing it's like my business that's
not the cult leader guy like that Jeff
antal that's that other dude but um you
know and every single one of them even
though some of them disagreed with each
other and disagreed with like you know
what they've what was said like on the
thing most of them seem to be of the
same opinion that the Tigers were the
main priority and also that Joe xotic
was kind of a piece of [ __ ] and deserve
to be where he was it's weird because
they didn't they only asked one of them
Jeff Lowe and his wife they only asked
them if they thought that Carol had
killed her husband they all say and they
said absolutely but I don't think he
asked any of the other ones he asked
them mostly things that were like
personal to them interestingly at least
one of them has had their teeth fixed in
the interim yeah but yeah it was it was
all like really interesting and when you
were saying about horses you know the
the producer guy who they interviewed
last Gila fortune he saw him kill a
horse like he's like this
[ __ ] like little old lady like
brought this horse to Joe exotics park
that had have been around here huh oh
maybe yeah it was like she couldn't take
care of anymore that's like please you
have so much room it's like can you
please take care of it and all this
other kind of stuff and you know he's
like and Joe was like oh of course I'll
do all this I'll take care of this horse
it's like the lady had no sooner left
because she was like crying and [ __ ] and
she no sooner left then Joe [ __ ] shot
the horse and then they cut it up and
fed it to the Tigers yeah and he's like
I don't take care of nobody's pets yeah
yeah which that's it's just a [ __ ] -
I guarantee you that happened around
2010 2011 during the collapse of the
[ __ ] horse industry Roger might have
yeah maybe everybody couldn't take care
everybody lost their jobs everybody lost
their jobs they couldn't take care of
these horses all these barns just
[ __ ] fell apart yeah and you know
they're just abandoned horses everywhere
and most of them starving but to d'lai
to the woman that you're gonna take care
of the day and then like be all nice
about it like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah was
really upset and stuff and the produce
then the producer guy was like a no
sooner had the woman like left the
property and then he just like pulled a
gun from his holster and shot them I
mean that's better than the horse just
starving to death but so that's that's
eventually what happened to sources they
were starved and then the vet came out
and put him down but usually what
happened a lot of but lie to the woman
about it yeah yeah I fall like why would
you the only thing he could have done
worse has just released the [ __ ]
horse alive into one of those cages
which some guys would have done that
yeah but that's like yeah yeah that's
there but yeah so so you know if you
really wanted to see like what happened
but all the follow up people like on
Tiger King and stuff like a lot of the
questions that he asked for like kind of
jokey but um it was still pretty
interesting I think like the the
producer guy the the one that worked for
Inside Edition I can't wear what his
name is but um they saved him for last
because he clearly was the best one when
he was the best one in the regular show
to like he seemed to have the most
insight about it cuz he was there for a
long time and yeah he lived there and
was filming all of this [ __ ] so he saw
some messed up and he was like the most
articulate about explaining oh I've had
a couple you people ask me about jokes
otic
Facebook and [ __ ] then you know don't I
was a brought back then I was like nah
[ __ ] that dude yeah I don't take it the
wrong way I didn't know he was as bad as
that but what I saw having an experience
in the horse industry from what I saw I
could pretty much knew what I was
dealing with I just didn't realize he
was that bad I thought one of the things
that he was doing was kittens are born
and those and those this they can't take
care of them all so what they'll do is
they'll turn them into like padding
exhibits they'll put them on a damn bus
you know it'll rent a bus and then they
drive the [ __ ] around people can come
into the bus and pet the [ __ ] tiger
yeah the pet Tigers they do that for a
few months until they're too big Nana
gassim yeah I put the put the baby
Tigers down which i think is despicable
that is so sick of all yeah but you got
a look man there aren't very many Tigers
in the wild and there isn't much wild
left if you have a bunch of these Tigers
these cats and you can't afford to keep
them all you should go in there neuter
those things and have a very small small
breeding population yeah it seems like
that'd be easy that would be the easiest
thing to do then to go out there and let
these things have kittens and then kill
the kittens because that's [ __ ] but
these guys are crooks you know they're
like cults they're trying to make every
I can kind of understand it they have to
make as much money as possible to feed
the damn Tigers that the hell yeah
that's not cheap I get that they can't
even really pay the employees that they
have so I see the temptation and they're
selling kittens I'd guarantee I knew the
dude was selling the kid oh yeah you
know well he seemed like he was good he
was just on the grift he's gonna get as
much money as possible doing whatever
pasta legal or not it's just a weird
situation because if you call the
authorities authorities come in there
kill every one of those cats yeah that's
like a no-win situation and it's like
interestingly like watching this like
the more I found out about Joe exotic
and like I said I know that there was
like a longer like a put like a several
part like podcast that was like that
came out like a few years before this
documentary and I haven't listened to
that yet but just from like researching
about it there was a lot of bad [ __ ]
about him that they didn't really even
mention in the documentary the Netflix
one or they just kind of like skimmed
over so seeing this was kind of like a
little more eye opening because you know
if you just watched the documentary and
it's like he seems he doesn't seem like
a good guy but he doesn't seem quite as
bad as he apparently really is like they
made him look a little bit better I
thought what he did to the chimps was
pretty [ __ ] bad
- that's kept him locked up and they
never even could [ __ ] even hang out
with each other yeah that's my stuff
that's like doing that to like children
yeah well he's living in a cage now so
now he knows what that's like yeah [ __ ]
they shouldn't let him 22 years I think
it's pretty steep for what he did I
think he needs to do more time yeah I
mean I could understand maybe five six
years although the one guy like the long
haired blonde guy that he was the first
one they interviewed he's basically like
yeah he's gonna die in there and [ __ ]
him I don't think so pretty much what he
said I don't think so I thought he
probably won't get out I think it'd be
out in about four or five years that's
that thing yeah cuz that like you said
that does seem I mean he did [ __ ] up
[ __ ] but what he got charged with he
didn't kill anybody
he just solicit he just solicited which
is bad but he was so dumb he was doing
that in public like it wasn't even like
it wasn't even against the law I wasn't
even against the law that it was a joke
right you know like you can't really get
away with oh that's some stupid [ __ ]
because that is very stupid what that
what you can do is you see one dude
joking about killing her and if you
don't like that person have something to
gain for for it you can go and kill that
person and Joe would get blamed that's
what I mean so even if I understand what
he's thinking if you don't let other
people hell with your [ __ ] thinking
yes I'm I learned you don't let other
people really know what you're thinking
because an enemy will go we'll find some
angle to come at you with if they know
[ __ ] about you yeah I mean like I said
if anything had happened to her then
that would be the first person there
because he made [ __ ] all those videos
like blaming her like shooting her in
the face and yeah like you know setting
yourself up for a [ __ ] phone yeah
that's dumb as hell dumb he doesn't
really seem like this brightest crayon
and I was dumb
I think it's dumb guy and cowardly
turned out he was scared of the second
Tigers yeah there's a fake trying to be
something he wasn't prided even know
much about the part that might and then
here's another thing turns out that
wasn't his voice on those music videos
he can't say I suspected as much he
can't sing because even when I was like
listen to the song I'm like that doesn't
sound anything like his speaking voice
which some people have that but I was
kind of like suspicious and then I
looked it up later and it's not him not
him sing and say yeah big ass
[ __ ] that's what I know he's a
fake lion tamer
he's a fake [ __ ] actually caught
himself a zoo owner I guess yes
he's also fixing things sometimes like
people like that that are really
outrageous and over-the-top and stuff
like that's because they're
overcompensating or something which I
definitely think was the case and it's
like some psychiatrist needs to get in
on that [ __ ] is going on there AMC is
going through the motions of filing for
bankruptcy got a lot of people thinking
oh no they're gonna pull through
somebody's gonna I don't think so
but they're gonna do is they're gonna
let AMC die and another company can go
on to go through there and [ __ ] buy F
pieces of AMC during liquid liquidation
that way you don't have to [ __ ] carry
that eight north at five billion dollars
of debt that AMC has I still kind of
think so kind of think that's the end of
the movie theater I think that's the end
of the focus the studio bar the
multiplex and multiplex is I think it'll
AMC will come back maybe in little
pieces and they'll be smaller you know I
mean like people will buy up pieces of
it and rename it by the AMC's gone and
then some people think well Studios will
buy Studios can't buy it there's a bunch
of laws preventing it well yeah because
that would almost be like maybe not
necessarily like a monopoly but yeah it
would be something kind of like that
because you're controlling like the
distribution and you know the public I
think it i think that whole studio
theater model is obsolete they don't
want to hear that because they're like
well digital on-demand you can't make
enough money yes you can you can make a
lot of money just don't spend so much
money making a [ __ ] movie yeah I mean
they don't just don't make a 300 million
your problem telling the stupid you know
but I make a lot of $10,000,000 yes but
you know the reason why they're doing
that is they're laundering money and
they're [ __ ] payin they're doing weird
[ __ ] with all their friends it's it's
organized crime if you asked me if you
really look into it that's that's what
they're really doing there's no reason
to make a [ __ ] 300 300 million dollar
movie and then struggle to make you know
money back on it that's just dumb you
know I mean there's got to be another
reason why they're doing that they must
be laundering money that's something I
don't think oh yeah because then they
complain when they don't make a billion
dollars like we lost our asses well then
why'd you [ __ ] make it yeah you know
that was such a long shot so I don't
believe what they say there's ulterior
motives and all that make a bunch of
little movies you know but they don't
want to do that they got debts to pay
and they gotta pay all these man shits
[ __ ] them man let them let them [ __ ]
collapse they've been doing that for
generations yeah you know what I mean
they've been [ __ ] running that [ __ ]
into the ground they can't come up with
anything new let little guys do it yeah
this movie's we've been watching on xbox
are [ __ ] better than a lot of these
big movies that they want to make us
watch yeah I mean to be fair some of
them look really stupid but it's like
the ones that we've actually paid to
watch I've actually been quite good yeah
VFW was good the Dare was good you know
a lot of that shit's [ __ ] really good
and they didn't AMC didn't show it in
the theater in our theater yeah might
have been showed elsewhere I don't
really know you're not not around here
welcome um another thing too I'd
recently just today I got an email from
YouTube and apparently because I guess
the bigger channels like if you had over
like 50,000 or 100,000 subscribers or
something you could do something called
YouTube memberships which was
essentially like a patreon model where
you could have people pay like five
bucks a month and give them like extra
YouTube content or like things like that
well I got an email today that said that
I was eligible to do that even though I
don't even think we have 10,000
subscribers but they said yeah well
we're expanding it out like four more
you
and we thought maybe you you know you
would like to do it so I don't know it's
like I might be able I don't know I
might enable it
unable to see yeah anyway you know if
anybody wants doesn't want to go through
patreon and going through that we can go
I mean I haven't decided yet I haven't
done it yet because I've decided like
what cuz you have to do perks and stuff
like that like you doing patreon okay um
they suggest that you do you can make
your little you can make little little
emojis like your little custom emojis
little badges and things that people can
have that they can comment with you can
do like Members Only community posts you
can do Members Only videos just like you
can do on patreon yeah so I figured
maybe you know like I said I'll think
about like what kind of perks we gonna
do cuz it might we might end up having
to do like short extra videos and [ __ ]
like that
we'll do a similar to what we do with
patreon members you know now something
we I have run into a problem with some
people to the head didn't get a shirt
you didn't get a shirt because you
didn't answer what size do you want we
all send out a [ __ ] email to all our
patrons well you know when when shirt
time comes up asking them what size they
want yeah if you don't ever answer
anyway probably maybe what 20% of them
don't answer yeah you don't answer you
don't get shirt yeah because I don't
want to send like a wrong size send you
the wrong size now some people to some
people do particularly on patreon even
though usually if you're a $20 and over
patron you know I have asked that you
put your mailing address in there but
some people haven't or have chosen not
to so much like then I was like you know
it so then I'll say case hot size and
like let me know if your what your
address is so I can send it and then
every now and then like people don't
answer and it's like I can't like I do
try to send stuff to the people's
regular email and their patreon thing
and everything like that and if you
don't answer after a little while it's
like we just have to start getting on it
we just assume you don't give a [ __ ]
some people won't give a [ __ ] about
shirt I understand yeah which you know
that's fine for you it's just kind of
like you know I'm just saying I don't
want people getting like upset if they
didn't like a rhythm you offer some Bob
is like I never got my shirt and I said
because you never answered the Danny
yeah I guess I did yeah that's what I
mean if you don't answer I'm just gonna
assume like you know cuz I don't know I
don't know I don't remember I have like
a lot of info
like and we have like a lot of patrons
who need shirts and also people that
send me money on PayPal and stuff like
that and I try to get them a shirt too
if they send me enough money and so it's
a lot of people to keep track of so I
don't remember like from you know from
time to time like what sighs like you
got last time or so you know I can't
remember yeah so it's but it's the thing
about it is that if you ever get [ __ ]
over just contact us yeah I mean we're
behind now because you know this [ __ ]
happened because all this [ __ ] happened
and we can't get to Michael's begin and
even like the the site that I order
shirts from is like you know there
shit's kind of like mostly closed down
and there shit's all behind so we
haven't been able to go out and get any
supplies and make new ones there's gonna
be a shared date coming ups but yeah as
soon as we like get that because I still
got to finalize a new design and
everything like that but yeah I was just
like saying about I might do that
YouTube membership thing I'll just
figure out maybe I can do like early
access on there to just like I do with
patreon and give people the link I can
do like you know just we can do just
like fun little extra videos to put on
there that only we've got a DMX bar DMX
and bought some lights we're gonna get
some background colored background we're
doing giallo lighting back here yeah we
got I don't like the way it looks I
don't fear it looks too boring so I'm
like well that is like a million times
better than like wait was it door yes
because we turned everything around like
in though we got lights in here you know
damn studio lights we're gonna set up
more stage lights and stuff in the back
oh yeah look we're gonna get like red
and green and blue yeah we'll figure out
a way to light us a little bit better
too because we talked about how how
[ __ ] pale we look we don't look this
honky issue in person I don't I do
we don't yeah she does it's just the
color of this room and the way the
lights bouncing around in here you know
me we look very pale but it's it's not
actually like that oh well this is I I
mean I think it's accurate I am actually
this pasty but I do actually go outside
yeah we wouldn't know it but yeah but I
think that's probably all um did we say
yesterday that you made like a really
really [ __ ] kick-ass
curry no I don't know
yeah we don't you thing about making
another one right now it's not really
Korea making that damn call yeah you
really get India peas and potatoes yeah
yeah oh yeah okay so we haven't made it
in a long time but I guess you can yeah
we don't have like a [ __ ] ton of meat I
guess cuz like you know this because of
the [ __ ] shortages and whatnot or
just mostly can't yeah and it's like so
yesterday he was like man we got like a
couple cans of chickpeas that have been
in there for ya got a bunch of white
potatoes got a bunch of white potatoes
and [ __ ] like that we'd have any cream
we didn't have nothing but it's like he
put together this really really good
like champion tato curry
yeah and it's delicious yeah and we just
had some like early because Indian food
gets better like a subsequent it's good
it's really good the first day but then
second third second and third day it
just gets better better as all the
spices kind of like cooler and stuff
like that I'm making you guys hungry
aren't I yeah I gotta be I gotta go stir
the pot oh yeah he's okay so he's making
another one another addition he's got to
go figure that out so I hope you guys
are doing okay out there and we'll talk
to you again tomorrow